Let's first jump into how to set our projects up.
So the main feature we want to talk about here is the mobile HDR.
Mobile HDR has a huge impact on your project's performance.
So as you see on the left hand image here, with it turned off, your project will still
run fast, but you won't have the additional render features.
Whereas on the right hand side here, you can see it enabled.
And although the project may run a little bit more slower, you'll still have lots of
the rendering features enabled.
So to keep the details from the HDR lighting, the mobile HDR rendering pipeline will draw
the HDR scene color buffer first.
It then converts it to the LDR post-process pass and sends it to the back buffer.
So these render target operations cost different performances based on the different hardwares,
but from a visual perspective, the LDR rendering pipeline dims and flats the highlight in the
scene.
So you need to tweak and hack your lighting settings and then the cube map also to compensate
for the final visual result.
Meanwhile, you may lose some of the post-process effects such as bloom and rendering effects
like that.
So it's good to keep in mind how you want to approach HDR on mobile.
Of course, there's always a payoff between performance, but if you're looking for the
extra rendering features, it's worth highlighting this and turning it on in your project settings.